we're told that the following diagram
describes the volume of yellow and red
paint in an orange mixture
so we can see that for every 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 parts of yellow we have
one two three four five six seven eight
parts of red
they ask us what is the ratio of red
paint to total paint in the mixture so
pause this video and see if you can have
a go at that before we do it together
all right so if we want to think about
red paint it looks like we have every we
have eight parts red paint and if we
think about the ratio of that towards
total paint you might be tempted to put
a 12 there but that's not the total
paint that's just the yellow paint the
total paint for every eight parts red
would be the eight parts red plus the
twelve parts yellow so it'd be eight
plus twelve
which is twenty and this is true the
ratio of red paint to the total paint in
the mixture is eight to twenty
now you might not always see it
expressed this way because there's other
ways of writing an equivalent ratio some
that people would argue are actually
simpler another way to think about it is
this diagram where we see the red paint
it has eight parts right over here but
we could also describe it as four
groups of two
just like that because eight is
divisible by four
and if you divide the twelve parts of
yellow into four groups it's four groups
of three
and you'll see in a second why this is
really interesting
because we were able to break down both
of these into four groups
and when you do that you see very
clearly hopefully that for every two
parts of red
you have three parts of yellow for every
two parts of red you have three parts of
yellow two parts of red three parts of
yellow and then last but not least these
two parts of red and then those three
parts of yellow so for every two parts
of red you have three parts yellow now
once again the ratio that they're asking
isn't the ratio of red to yellow which
is two to three but you could just take
one of these groups and say all right
for every two parts of red i have one
two three four five parts of total paint
so you could say that the ratio is also
for every two parts of red i have five
parts of total paint and hopefully this
makes intuitive sense right here why
these two things are equivalent if for
every eight you have 20 total well if
you have a if you have if you divide
that by four for every two
of red you're going to have five